[Music]
in fastest concert ever news submitted
because o submitted by because I'm
Batman
but I'm Batman a band recently stunned
its audience with an eight-second
concert I don't know how you have a
second concert it is some Kanye [ __ ]
like some piece is that even enough for
like a full bar 2 1 2 3 feelings this
band here named golden bomber little
bomber what's the name of the band
that is helping all of like that's a
terrible name in the global Bob or also
known as Isis lookup book yeah so they
are a Japanese visual key air band
suddenly we have instruments so the
thing is the lead singer he's pretty
much the only musician in this entire
band because he writes the songs and he
writes the melodies so why does he even
need them wait wait hold on let me guess
which one that is is this one either
what do you open so the reason why there
he's like a warning face the other three
band members they're just they're more
for like props they don't know how to
play the instruments at all but they do
go on stage with instruments they
pretend to play and the other band
members it's been reported that they
don't even know their new songs until
after they're released to the public
that's another band members the only the
only ten the base year though their song
is before a performance so they can
figure out how they're going to perform
the song as well as I can come see you
guys mocking what kind of girl band is
it what's the story with a guy dude I
don't know but that's that's that's
their look they're just a really odd
band as it is the girl pop band you know
what I got looks like cloud kind of I
think this is the main singer
how come they don't want to learn the
songs that they're going to pretend
played before the goals oh they do they
did it right before Yeah right before
shot and I want the mute are their bands
have already heard their music and
that's when the other three band members
all so they're just up there playing
Aaron sorry no I mean they have real
instruments they're pretending so they
better cause an Arab band because
they're not technically playing the
instrument but at least they're honest
about it
like that's publicized patrocle
performance my question is are they
famous are they like how many years what
is their audience like when you really
so I'm going to show you two clips the
first one is going to be their eighth
second concert there's a chuck-e-cheese
bad news second clip is it's a little
just a little preview of what one of the
concerts look like so here we go an
actual like lost full-length glass the a
second is not is that fully just so you
guys know there were people at this mall
so this is this was a free concert where
our people had this mall that had waited
like six hours in advance that's so cool
six hours yeah and they have it three
minute countdown so you're going to see
the screen on the stage and it's like
counting down to a moment that the band
members jump on stage and it was a three
minute countdown they perform for eight
seconds and then all the fans are just
like maybe they were asking for like an
encore and then a couple minutes later
that's when they came back on and they
performed this on one one song one huh
one song that I know maybe it was like
they're responding to everyone never
like you have to do this ball concert
they're like okay we will and like I
tell you it's their new um a second song
oh [ __ ]
yes I breaking the world oh my gosh [ __ ]
you I really love you
that's a troll thank you hello is a
second concert now I'm going to show you
guys a little clip no nothing on court
but a clip of what's their concert
usually looks like oh is mama bear here
you go oh my god
if your house is gone before
and for you they know that I love an
instrument subject but do they all know
yeah little yeah no they're not even
playing the instruments they're dancing
why did he remind me of a baby hair bag
kid yeah well one of them but only
wasn't Yenta
the guy would make a deal with a black
big thing going on they must be really
good friends and he's the only
successful and he's like yo you guys I
want to make money wish you guys like
solderless aren't as good I would do
that add other vocalists out there
Japanese vocalist ya know their vocalist
aren't that great
maybe they focus on just a fake
instrument but you're easy though
they're pretty not the j-rock guys oh
like screaming show yeah they can do
some crazy [ __ ] maybe I'm thinking about
stuff that I like to hear
like j-pop are you saying like all
japanese vocalist just like in terms of
like vocals because you got some j-rock
guys got to rival like Queen stuff we
are the champion my friends is I'm very
nasally like the lane like when I sing
it's remote sabi burns all your nasal
hairs like vocalize [ __ ] like Europe
like UK like there are being soul it's
[ __ ] insane
no it's still popular over there like
they really do appreciate like music
music music I think it's mainly London
or UK yeah yeah hey you know I'm saying
like people like Jessie J are still
popping there's like high respect for
her like that type of music and that arm
B is still alive out there I'm like what
the [ __ ] man I'm in the wrong [ __ ]
country
no I like America go time except fishing
trip man the fishing ship makes people
soulful ass fried food always does it
though right chicken does it for us
that's the secret to the soul it is dude
I [ __ ] love fish and chips now with
Tok Tok Tok that's a [ __ ] innovative
and it's so like it's so odd but it's so
unique like an 8 second solid like it's
[ __ ] cool the trendsetters man
that they were going to listen to an
eight-second song no babe you song right
and they don't even know what it is
follow us must know that [ __ ] it's
coming like there's such trolls like
that would make me happy seeing that
they're recording that like after this
after the eight second concert was done
apparently a lot of the fans space or
just like so like like they loved it
they loved the fact that they did that
because they're they're really a weird
band as it is so I'm pretty sure like
they're a family we're like [ __ ] I mean
you wait longer at San Diego comic-con
for high watch way too much anime that
should sound like a Denis intro to me
that's the great part of it a lot of the
music there it feels like anime it does
dude I [ __ ] it mariel always seems this
one [ __ ] anime song all the time
butters hours ago I have to know the
lyrics cuz we've seen this a lot
kini go baby but you are yamato energy
Janet Morrow death I shoot them all the
time oh oh no Matt you don't know what
you're saying a little bit of it like if
you say uh-uh like she did so Jamie
gonna say mr. moto Jamie's by who Tommy
sing I just know a few words you in
there is that Brotherhood or normal I
think it's Brotherhood yeah but she
[ __ ] loves it dude hey Brotherhood
intro I think we're fourth one Japanese
like pop or anime music is so fast it
makes happy hardcore seem slow kidding
our course it's also check know kind of
EDM raises it's really fast
uh you guys talked about it before where
you guys are like it's so fast you can't
even make up they literally put the beat
after the other beat that just played I
thought they just zoom in on the [ __ ]
software they've got all the [ __ ]
kick drum I want to know what the story
is with this guy that has the only face
down like why aren't they all face
painting and why are you so worried I
feel like he masturbates disgust if you
can't share it's probably they do that
and don't explain it just at all all of
us I just get the kids ever explain why
they did this not but they all did it
whose kiss like it doesn't matter they
all did it you know like this one does
one guy
well they're all pretty much props in
the band so they probably could all be
their own characters nothing only guys
yes give me a bit he looks like the
clown from saw oh it was like when you
look at somebody like that the only
thing I think about is what is the girl
like that he's with yes that's what I'm
wondering what kind of girl likes him
exactly dude like what the [ __ ] is the
weirdo that [ __ ] dated that it was
like I love it the same weirdo that
would date this guy in that guy I don't
dress me like that dude what the [ __ ] do
I need to pull up all your [ __ ]
videos [ __ ] all wet would you thought
Uncle Sam oh I met her before I knew but
that she was going on okay I thought it
was weird and you [ __ ] around which is
good I and that's the weird part
you didn't get with him until JK they
knew what they were getting into you had
no idea no was the craziest man how
could Jessica the crazy cuz she knew all
the [ __ ] was a [ __ ] fan so that is
crazy she's like oh I thought that was
just a better illiterate Chinese man hey
now girls love guys with accents that's
what they say what's up you sexy [ __ ]
useless [ __ ] [ __ ] if you
want to follow us you could check out
all our [ __ ] links to the description
box below you [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that videos are up there
[Music]